thanks to kiwico for supporting this
episode
of journey to the micro cosmos click the
link in the description
to learn more and for a special offer
we're often running into examples of
endosymbiosis in the microcosmos like
this partnership between paramecium
bursaria
and the green algae chlorella the algae
lives inside the paramecium providing
sustenance
derived from its own photosynthetic
machinery in exchange for protection
from viruses that
linger outside the living borders of the
paramecium
this is one of those heartwarming tales
of the microcosmos
one small organism finds another even
smaller organism collaborating to create
a better life
for each but not all tales of
internalized organisms are so
peaceful and not all creatures found
inside a paramecium
are welcome guests this for reference is
a healthy paramecium you can see
the round healthy nuclei towards the
center of the organism
and this is another paramecium
it looks similar to the one we just saw
only now the nuclei
are filled with strange bumps
from some angles one of the nuclei looks
almost as if
it's full of crystals except
those aren't crystals when james
our master of microscopes came upon this
frosted looking nucleus
he recognized it from a paper he'd read
three years before
a paper that contained a photo of a
paramecium whose nucleus was filled with
needle-like bacteria
called halaspera
olaspera were first described by
voldemort hafken
in 1890. he'd been studying
paramecium caudatum when he noticed
these
parasitic organisms residing in the
nucleus
through his investigation hafken would
end up identifying
three species halaspora obtusa halaspera
angelada and halaspora elegons
while his work would prove important to
establishing the existence of these
bacteria
hofkins soon moved on to other research
interests
this pivot would put a temporary pause
to hollaspera discovery
but it would pay off in other ways
hafkin would go on to create vaccines
against both cholera and the plague
so you know not bad today
there are nine species known to us they
differ
not just in appearance but in where they
infect their hosts
in some cases certain species will live
in a paramecium's
macronucleus while others prefer the
micronucleus
and some hellospherous species may also
only
target specific paramecium species while
others will infect more indiscriminately
but the process of infection
is a shared one it begins with
getting eaten
[Music]
the paramecium may just be casually
munching on its surroundings when they
end up phagocytosing some of the
halaspera
which then end up in the ciliates food
vacuoles
the bacteria aren't modal meaning they
can't
move on their own but within an hour
of getting into the paramecium these
surprising escape artists will make
their way
out of the vacuole which is good for
them because everything in there is
going to get digested
and use the paramecium's own systems
to get into their nucleus of choice
how do they choose their target nucleus
we do not know
but when they get there the halaspera
invade
at this infectious point in their lives
the halaspera
are shaped like rods and will be around
10 to 20 microns long
but once they've settled into their
nuclear homes the trespassing bacteria
switch
modes shortening to about 1 to 3 microns
long
they also begin reproducing dividing and
filling up the nucleus with more and
more of their own kind
until the time comes to infect a new
paramecium
in general parasites have two choices
when it comes to widening their
infectious net
horizontal transmission or vertical
transmission
for horizontal transmission the parasite
has to leave their current host
to find a new one but for vertical
transmission the parasite
just waits for their host to reproduce
so they can infect the new offspring
each method of transmission comes with
its own set of advantages
and disadvantages horizontal
transmission for example is great
if you're an organism that wants to make
as much
use as possible out of your host but you
do
run the risk of potentially killing them
in the process
meanwhile vertical transmission involves
waiting for your host
to reproduce and then infecting the new
offspring
this might be less risky than venturing
out into the unknown to find a new home
but it will require both delicacy and
patience ensuring that you take just
enough advantage of your host to survive
but not so much that your host cannot
survive long enough
to replicate different parasites
balance the choice between these
transmission styles based on
a number of conditions but the halaspera
can actually switch between horizontal
and vertical transmission
based on how the paramecium seems to be
doing
after it infects a new paramecium and
switches to its reproductive stage
the halaspera will keep doubling and
doubling inside the nucleus
and if the paramecium is growing rapidly
then it will be
dividing a lot into daughter cells and
with each
division of the ciliate the bacteria
will be distributed between
the daughter cells as well this is
vertical transmission and it works
great for hollaspera unless the
paramecium's growth
starts to slow down at which point the
bacteria will switch back to their
infectious form
and leave the host to find a new home
the halaspera can't survive outside
their host
so this is the one time they will leave
the safe confines of the paramecium
despite halaspora's infectious nature
and paramecium's prevalence around the
world
it's actually kind of difficult to find
hollaspera infected paramecium out in
the wild
they've only been documented in the
northern hemisphere and even then
sightings can be infrequent so it was
actually pretty exciting to find them in
our samples
even if it means our paramecium are
dealing with an unwelcome
guest have developed
various strategies to prevent hollaspera
infection
some can't ingest the infectious forms
while others
seem capable of blocking the bacteria
from entering the cytoplasm or nucleus
and given that infection by halaspera
has been
associated with lower rates of sexual
reproduction and abnormalities in the
host
it makes sense that the paramecium would
evolve a defense
however there have been cases where a
particular species of halaspera
will infect a particular species of
paramecium
and the host actually benefits
from the interaction in one case
the host was better able to survive
abrupt changes in temperature and in
another
it was able to withstand changes in
osmotic
pressure but this is not a universal
experience it depends
on the combination of host and parasite
it's hard not to look at all of this
from the paramecium's point of view
to not see this as a larger organism
that finds itself
contending with microbial invaders but
the halaspera
is also just trying to survive as well
in the one world it knows how to survive
in
if only that world wasn't another
organism
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us and thank you
again
to kiwiko for supporting this episode
kiwi ko
super cool hands-on projects for kids
that make learning
fun with a kiwi co-subscription each
month
the kid in your life will receive a fun
engaging new project which will help
develop their
creativity and confidence they have
eight subscription lines each catering
to different age groups and topics and
each box
comes with all the supplies needed for
that month's project
meaning you won't have to make any extra
trips to the store
in their tinker crate intended for ages
9 and up you can get your very own
robotics kit
and use it to build an actual walking
robot
these projects are a great resource for
learning at home
and offer fantastic hands-on activities
to balance the overload of screen time
from virtual classes or video chats
and kiwico also has a store that allows
you the flexibility of purchasing
individual projects
with no subscription needed so head on
over to kiwico.com
microcosmos and use the code microcosmos
or click the link in the description
to get 20 off everything on the site
thank you as always to our patrons all
of the people on the screen right now
you are the people that keep this show
happening
we love that you love what we do
and we love you for it if you want to be
one of those people and support this
show you can go to patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes
james check out jam and germs on
instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's very likely
a subscribe button somewhere nearby